Let's get started by talking about some materials and instances which are just child versions
of materials.
We'll talk about how to create some dynamic shadows in this section.
So to start off with, let's talk about some textures, materials and models.
So textures, we can pack multiple textures into one texture using the RGB and alpha channels.
So you can learn more about this by going to the Unreal documentation page under rendering
materials and material instances.
But essentially what we're talking about here is you'll see in a slide in a second that
we can put different maybe logos or noise effects or something that you only need black
and white information for.
If we pack a texture into a single channel, it doesn't come with any color information
because it's a single channel, but we can also then take that texture input and maybe
multiply it by a certain color or give it a certain effect, which you'll see in a moment
here.
So if you want multiple textures that only need grayscale information to start with,
you can think about packing multiple textures into the different channels if you want.
And you can use the RGB and alpha channels.
You can see in this image here, we've got a white pin at the top of a, it's a base color
in this instance, but you can see that it can be used for a texture sample.
So if you pull off the white channel here, it's all channels and you obviously see the
RGB and B outputs as well as the alpha output at the bottom.
So you can actually pull information from individual channels, which is super useful.
We can also use UI texture modes, which we'll touch upon in a second.
And then we can also minimize texture lookups by using material instances, which will really
help with performance.
So you only create one master material and then you create material instances based on
that parent material.
And again, you can find that material instancing documentation online on the unrealengine.com
documentation if needed.
And then also we'll look at the models and how to minimize certain elements, whether
it be in the mesh optimization.
So for this project, say we have a target of a hundred thousand triangles for mid to
high tier hardware.
Again, mileage may vary depending on the project.
You'll have different performance requirements.
And you can also look into some Nanite mesh optimization, which is an Unreal Engine feature
in a performance issue with the number of triangles on screen.
So we can look at the models, the optimization for the models.
We can also look at how many materials and material instances we're using.
And then also if we have a lot of textures being used unnecessarily, say we're only pulling
in a gray value or black and white value from a texture sample and we're using all four
channels to pull it in.
Maybe you could just pack it into the red channel and use the green and blue channel
and alpha channel for another texture.
So just things to consider there when looking at some optimization for your projects.
When we're looking at materials, we have some baked in functionality.
So materials cannot be edited at runtime.
So you'll see this material graph here.
We essentially whatever we hook up here, that is what happens at runtime.
However, we can expose certain parameters here into dynamic values.
So you can if you had a texture sample, you can right click on that texture sample
and you can see the convert to parameter at the top of the list there.
And that will mean that that parameter then can be edited at runtime, which we can use
material instances from.
So instances can derive from parent materials and they just inherit all the functionality
and then anything that is a parameter can then be edited at runtime.
So if you want to create a material with a core shared logic, then derive an instance
to control the specific parameters.
That's how you would change things at runtime.
And again, the Unreal Engine documentation on rendering and materials will give you a
lot of mileage here in terms of knowing what properties you can edit.
And then looking at the main difference between material and material instances.
Materials contain instructions and functions cannot be altered when the program is running,
as we said in the previous slide.
They can be applied directly to a mesh or a UI element or some kind of parent of an
instance, whereas material instances require this parent material.
So you can see the material instance window down at the bottom here and you'll see that
parent box here.
That essentially means we've got a parent material sending us certain instructions
and then the parameters that we can change are in this top section here.
So we can expose parameters that can be edited at runtime.
We can't change the instructions or functions inside the source material.
So that's just something to be mindful of there.
So for today's session, let's go ahead and import the hot and cold texture from your asset pack.
We just want to make sure the compression settings are the user interface 2D.
So when we talk about compression settings, which you'll see just here, compression settings,
you just want to make sure that texture is compressed correctly.
So then let's get started by creating a new material.
So we want to have imported the icon texture and then we want to create a new material.
So I'll just jump into the editor quickly to show you how to make a material if you're on show.
With your editor open, you just want to maybe create a new folder for material specific
content.
So you could right click and call this materials.
So I've just right clicked on content, new folder, and you can also just add here a new folder.
And then also when we're in our materials, you can either just right click in this gray space
in the content browser and go to material or again, you can go to add material.
So let's take a look at our material options here.
So we've set the material domain to user interface.
So you can see here, make sure you don't have any nodes selected.
And you'll see on the left hand side, you'll see user interface.
And then we've set the blend mode to translucent.
So make sure those two options are set.
We have a scalar parameter in here called temp or in this image temperature.
So we just hold down the number one key and left click.
Or you can add a const one node, but number one and left click will give you this.
And then just right click, convert to a parameter and call it either temperature or temp.
Just remember what you call this for later on.
And then everything else, we've got two linear interpolates here.
We've got a subtract and we've got an add node.
To get these two color nodes, this is a const three.
So you can hold down three and left click on your keyboard.
And then just pick two different colors there.
So we have our texture sample.
You can select it in the content browser and then press T in here and left click.
And that will create a texture sample.
And because you've got it selected in your content browser,
it will automatically assign the texture that you had imported on the previous slide.
If not, you can drag and drop this texture sample from the content browser into here.
Or you can create an empty texture sample, click on the node.
And then on the left hand details panel, you'll see what texture to use.
And you just want to plug that in from the content browser.
And so here's a larger image of that if you want to see it up close.
So what we have here is we have the multiplier of the red and blue channels by their respective colors.
We have the lerp based on the scalar parameter, which is this temperature that we had.
And we just name this temperature.
Then the opacity from the texture sample goes straight into the opacity of the material input.
And then what we want to do is we want to save the material and close it.
And then if we right click on this material that we've created,
so you'll see this material in the content browser, you'll see the map.
What you want to do is you want to right click on this map and create instance from material.
So I'll just jump into the editor and show you that.
So if I have my material here, I can just right click create material instance.
And then this type of material will now pop up, which you can see is the instance version of this.
And by default, you should see the details panel selected in the top left.
If you have any other windows open, just make sure that the parent material is in the hot and cold
material and our temperature parameter is here.
And we can actually just click that temperature and we can now change this temperature.
So you can see our material when working is dialing between this cold to hot.
And if we just snap from zero to one, we can see that our material is changing.
So that's the result of the parameter that you want to achieve with your material
and then subsequently material instance.
Next up, we want to create the display vehicle material.
So in this, we'll be using some parameters, LURPS, PANNERS, and the Saturate and Clamp node.
But we'll apply this to the car model in the viewport.
And again, we'll go through step by step how we go about creating this.
So we have metallic and roughness.
Again, hold down number one on your keyboard to create these boxes.
Your nodes, these constants values may look a little bit different depending on what version
of Unreal Engine you're using.
In the more recent versions, you'll see a little value number inside this const one,
but the functionality will be the same.
So metallic to one, roughness 2.5 there.
And then we want to display three vectors.
So hold down number three on the keyboard and go from the gray to the green to the red.
And essentially, as the temperature value goes up,
we want the wing color to change from blue to red.
So that's essentially what we're doing here.
And we again want that parameter.
If we hold down number one on the keyboard, left click and go to temp,
and then right click and convert it to a parameter
just to name it that temperature value there as you did on the last material.
The display material is going to be a little bit different than what you saw on our previous material.
So nothing to be too worried about here if we just set it up step by step.
So the local position provides the meshes local x and y directions.
And then the divide mask adjust to shape it and resize it for the model.
So you can change the divide amount as needed for the size of your vehicle.
The airspeed is a parameter.
So again, just left click holding down number one and convert it to a parameter and name that airspeed.
Now, it's important to note when calling parameters with two words like this,
airspeed and even band frequency here,
if you capitalize the letter without a space in when you go to edit the parameter,
it will have a space there because you've gone from a lowercase letter to an uppercase letter.
So Unreal Engine detects that and creates a space in the actual user facing parameter settings.
So that's just a really nice way.
You shouldn't really add spaces to parameter names.
It's not a terrible thing to do, but it's just a good practice to get into.
It comes from more of the coding language side.
So the airspeed is a parameter that we can drive up and down through the UI later.
So it's important to add that.
And make sure to give the panner an x or y value of one,
depending on the direction that the car is facing or it won't move at all.
A component mask here allows us to cut out the color channels and output what's left.
So if you mask a basic coordinate,
G creates a top bottom gradient and R creates a left right gradient.
So if you want a top bottom gradient, use your green channel, G channel.
And then if you want to use the R channel, that will create a left right gradient.
And then we've got a multiply.
You can hold down M on the keyboard for multiply.
And then sine provides a repeating wave pattern.
So then we just want to clamp that at the end there.
You can also go from sine to a saturate node if you want.
That makes things a little bit cleaner.
So you can drag off and do saturate.
So you can either clamp or saturate there.
And then we just want to make sure all the connections are hooked up there.
So this is a series of nodes that we hooked in there.
We've done our roughness and metallic values.
And then we've got our color controls here.
And then as before, we have our master material.
So you can right click on that material, select create material instance,
and then just name it some version of what you called the master material, underscore instance.
Unreal Engine will automatically add the underscore inst,
but just name it whatever naming convention is consistent to your project.
And then you can just tick these parameters and just alter them and see,
have a play around with the material,
get a feel for what it is actually doing inside the material editor,
and then we'll be able to apply it to our blueprint.